Let's go next to our caller from the 9 0 3
area code who's calling today from 9 0 3.
My name is Vince.
Hey, Vince, what's up?
Do pregnant women get $500 from the recovery
package?
I can't imagine that they do.
You can or you can.
I cannot imagine that they do, no.
But then the Republicans would have to use
a reason for that.
Right.
Yeah, well, I offer I guess it's not a person,
right?
All right.
You deny them the $500.
You have to admit that they're not full blown
kids.
Yeah.
Now, that's a I've not heard that raised before,
and it's an interesting one.
And I wonder what Republicans would say.
I mean, certainly some of them would probably
say, well, by the time that kids born, all
of this is going to be resolved, then, of
course, a lot of those kids are going to be
born next week.
And that's obviously not going to be the case.
But that is interesting.
I wonder what they would say if pressed on
that.
And what do you think about how Biden just
picked Obama as his running mate?
I did not hear that.
April Fools.
Gotcha.
All right.
Thank you so much, Vince, very much appreciated
the call.
Have a go.
All right, take care.
Yeah.
You didn't get me with that one.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine
for nine area code who is calling today from
9 4 9.
Hey, this is Kenny calling from 949.
Yeah.
Kenny, what's going on?
Hey, so I actually have a question that's
not relate to this whole Corona virus thing,
so.
Just about governing in general.
I think one of the things that comes when
attempting to define change is how we do a
lot of our institutional norms and rules that
used to govern us in the past.
One example is that while we only govern for
three days of the week, that a planet basically
distinguishes before yes, course, bringing
back some of the institutions and norms of
the Congress that we used to have such as
that.
You know, Kenny, your connection was so garbled.
Were you asking whether we should bring back
some of these conventions?
Yes.
I mean, it depends on which one you know,
the entire thing about governing on three
days instead of five.
There's arguments that you want our elected
officials spending more time in their districts
with their constituents rather than in Washington,
D.C..
You know, I can sort of see both sides of
that.
I don't know that there's any one kind of
simple answer to that question, unfortunately.
Right.
It's just that there was a recent vise interview
that was heard a couple months ago about how
some of the former congressmen who are now
leading you have suggested that this is actually
a very big problem because it doesn't allow
them to form a working legislative relationship
with their other fellow congressmen, because,
quite frankly, people spend more time out
of Washington that they spend in Washington.
So as a result, nothing ever happens in Washington.
Yeah, I mean, maybe the happy medium would
be that they're doing four days a week instead
of three, but not five.
Like, you know, we're kind of really slicing
and dicing things here.
But there's no doubt that, you know, we would
the question that really needs to be asked
is, would more bills get passed if they spent
an extra day there or would there just be
more debate and more filibustering?
But the same amount gets done.
And if more bills are passed, is that objectively
good?
Maybe some of the bills that would get passed
aren't things that we want.
So I just think that there's more the devil
is really in the details there.
Right.
It's just that one of the consequences said
being less of Washington is that people are
campaigning more.
Yes.
One of the problems that we often hear is
about the problem of money in politics as
well as people constantly campaigning.
Right.
And as a result, money has more power and
people are suggesting maybe we ought to sort
of the campaign season.
Well, it turns out, I think that by restoring
some of our congressional schedule and the
way we used to have it, like we did before
the 90s, that we would be able to it at butonly
fix this problem of having too much money
in politics and people campaigning too much
and having too much of a campaign.
Kenny, you're fading out, so I'm gonna let
you go, your connection is abhorrent, unfortunately,
but that's the best possible argument I could
imagine for spending more time in D.C., which
is just keep people off the campaign trail.
I would love to see that combined with public
financing of elections as well.
And a date certain before which you cannot
start campaigning like maybe, you know, limit
the full campaign to six months where you
have, you know, three months for the primary
campaigning and then the final three months
leading up to the vote or something like that,
because all too far too much time is spent
campaigning, especially with two year terms
in the House of Representatives.
You essentially start campaigning a few months
after you're sworn in.
And it is a major, major waste of time and
the American people suffer as a result.